Si aún no han ordenado, a mí me gusta el rigatoni con la salsa de tomate con especias
que va mucho mejor con las enfermedades del intestino delgado.
(Risas)
Lo siento, simplemente sentí que debía hacer algo así por todo el arreglo del escenario.
No, lo que quiero hacer es llevarlos hacia 1854
en Londres por unos cuantos minutos y contarles la historia --
brevemente -- de esta epidemia
que en muchos sentidos, según mi opinión, creó el mundo en el que vivimos hoy,
y particularmente el tipo de ciudades en las que vivimos.
Este año, 1854, a la mitad del siglo XIX,
en la historia de Londres es fascinante por diversas razones.
Pero creo que la más importante de ellas es
que Londres era una ciudad de 2.5 millones de habitantes,
y era la ciudad más grande de todo el planeta.
Pero también era ciudad más grande jamás construida.
Y la sociedad Victoriana trataban de hacer sus vidas
y al mismo tiempo inventar una nueva manera de vivir:
Esta manera de vivir que, como ustedes saben, llamamos sociedad urbana.
Y en este punto, alrededor de 1850, esta sociedad urbana era un completo desastre.
Ellos tenían un estilo de vida urbano similar al de una metrópoli industrial moderna
con una infraestructura anticuada.
Para darles una idea, la gente
Tenía fosas sanitarias (para excrementos y orina) en sus sótanos. Que llegaban a tener hasta 60 centímetros de profundidad.
Y simplemente acumulaban sus desechos en esas fosas
y esperaban que algún día desapareciera,
y claro que nunca desaparecía.
Y toda esta suciedad se acumuló hasta el punto
en que no se podía transitar por la ciudad.
Era una ciudad con olores desagradables por todas partes. No solo por las fosas sanitarias
sino también por la cantidad de ganado que vivía en la ciudad.
No sólo los vivían caballos, sino que había también muchas vacas en los áticos para el consumo personal de leche,
las llevaban allí con poleas y las mantenían confinadas
hasta que dejaban de dar leche y se morían,
y eran literalmente arrastradas hasta las calderas que trataban huesos al final de la calle.
Así bien, si caminaban por Londres en esta época
quedarían abrumados por este terrible olor.
Y lo que a fin de cuentas sucedió es que el sistema de salud de aquel entonces
estaba convencido de que era el olor lo que estaba matando a todos,
lo que estaba creando estas enfermedades
que arrasaban la ciudad cada tres o cuatro años.
Pero era el cólera el verdadero asesino de esta época.
Llegó a Londres en 1832, y cada cuatro o cinco años
llegaba una nueva epidemia para acabar con 10,000 o 20,000 personas en Londres
y en todo el Reino Unido.
Y así las autoridades se convencieron de que el olor era el problema.
Debían deshacerse del olor.
Y así idearon algunas acciones primitivas
como parte del sistema de salud de la cuidad,
una de ellas fue el Acta contra el ruido y olores,
que implementaron tan bien como pudieron
para vaciar las fosas y tirar todos esos residuos al río.
Porque si sacamos esos residuos de las calles, olerá mucho mejor,
y -- cierto, también tomamos agua del río.
Así que lo que terminó sucediendo fue
que el brote de cólera se extendió
porque, como ahora sabemos, el cólera está en el agua.
Es una enfermedad transmitida por el agua y no por nada que esté en el aire.
No es algo que se huela o inhale; es algo que se come.
Así que uno de los principales movimientos de salud pública del siglo XIX
envenenó el suministro de agua de Londres de mejor manera
que lo que hubiera soñado cualquier bio-terrorista moderno.
Así se veía Londres en 1954,
y en medio de todas estas muertes y de las condiciones ofensivas,
en medio de toda esta confusión científica
acerca de las causas de las muertes
que un hombre talentoso llamado John Snow,
quien era un médico en Soho, Londres,
y que estuvo diciendo por unos cuatro o cinco años
que el cólera era, en realidad, una enfermedad transmitida en el agua,
pero sin convencer a nadie.
Las autoridades de salud ignoraron por mucho tiempo lo que ese médico decía.
Sin embargo él presentó su caso en numerosos artículos y realizó varios estudios,
pero nada que tuviera un verdadero impacto.
Y parte de esto --- y lo que hace más interesante esta historia --
es que, en varios sentidos, es un gran caso de estudio acerca de cómo suceden los cambios culturales.
Como es que una buena idea finalmente triunfa contra otras no tan buenas.
Snow estuvo trabajando por mucho tiempo con estos conceptos que todo el mundo ignoraba.
Hasta que un día, el 28 de agosto de 1854,
una pequeña de cinco meses y cuyo nombre desconocemos,
sólo sabemos que era la bebé Lewis,
sufrió de cólera en la Calle Broad # 40.
No podemos identificar gran cosa en este mapa, pero este es el mapa
que recibe la mayor atención en la segunda mitad de mi libro.
Es en el centro de Soho, en una vecindad de la clase trabajadora
Esta niña se enferma y resulta que la fosa,
que ellos todavía conservaban, a pesar del Acta sobre ruidos y olores,
cerca de una popular bomba de agua,
o sea un pozo que era conocido por tener la mejor calidad de agua en Soho,
y al que todos los residentes de Soho y alrededores asistían.
Así, esta pequeña niña de manera inadvertida terminó
contaminando el agua de este pozo tan popular,
y entonces una de las más terribles epidemias en la historia de Inglaterra
se desencadenó dos o tres días mas tarde.
Literalmente, el diez porciento del vecindario murió en siete días,
y muchos más hubieran muerto si la gente no hubiera huido
después de que empezó el primer brote.
Así fue que a partir de este evento
Que se presentaron escenas de familias enteras muriendo
después de 48 horas de cólera,
solos en sus departamentos de una sola habitación, en sus pequeñas casas.
Fue un evento terrible.
El Doctor Snow, quien vivía cerca, escucho del brote,
y en un increíble acto de valor se dirigió al corazón de la bestia
porque pensaba que un brote tan concentrado
podría ayudarle a convencer a la gente de que,
en realidad, la amenaza del cólera estaba en el suministro de agua y no en el aire.
Sospechaba que un brote tan concentrado
probablemente provenía de una sola fuente.
Una sola cosa que todos los afectados hicieron
porque en este caso no se diseminaba lentamente, como normalmente lo hacían
esta clase de infecciones.
Así que empezó a entrevistar a la gente
Y eventualmente consiguió la ayuda de esta otra persona asombrosa,
que es casi como otro protagonista del libro.
Este hombre, Henry Whitehead, que era un presbítero local,
y que no era en absoluto un hombre de ciencia, pero que estaba super conectado socialmente.
El conocía a todos en el vecindario,
y pudo ayudar a rastrear
muchos de los casos de personas que, o habían tomado agua del pozo,
o que no lo habían hecho.
Y eventualmente Snow pudo hacer un mapa del brote.
Y encontró que cada ves más personas de las que tomaban agua se ponían enfermas
Y gente que no había tomado del pozo no se estaba enfermando.
Y pensó acerca de la manera de representarlas
algo así como una tabla estadística de personas viviendo en diferentes zonas,
y gente que no se había contagiado,
pero finalmente dio con la idea
de que necesitaba algo más tangible.
Algo que diera sentido y una mejor perspectiva
a toda esta actividad que había estado pasando en el vecindario.
Así que creó este mapa,
y terminó representando todas las muertes en las zonas aledañas
como barras negras en cada domicilio.
Y como pueden ver en este mapa, el pozo está en el centro de todo
y pueden ver que una casa en la misma área
tuvo hasta quince muertos.
El mapa es en realidad más grande.
Conforme nos vamos alejando del pozo,
las muertes empiezan a ser menos frecuentes.
Y pueden ver entonces que este "veneno"
provenía de este pozo como pueden ver.
Así, con la ayuda de este mapa,
y con el apoyo de una mayor difusión
que Snow realizó durante los siguientes años
y en la que también Whitehead colaboró
las autoridades empezaron a darse cuenta.
Tomo mucho más tiempo de lo que nos gusta pensar,
pero en 1866, cuando el siguiente gran brote de cólera llegó a Londres,
las autoridades habían sido convencidas --- en parte por esta historia,
y en parte por este mapa --- de que el agua era la del problema.
Y para ese entonces ya habían comenzado a construir un sistema de drenaje,
e inmediatamente fueron a la zona de este brote
y le dijeron a todos que empezaran a hervir el agua.
Y esa fue la última vez que Londres estuvo cerca de una epidemia de cólera.
Parte de esta historia, bueno, es una historia aterradora,
es una historia oscura y es una historia
que se sigue repitiendo en muchas de las ciudades en desarrollo del mundo.
Es también una historia fundamentalmente optimista,
que nos dice que es posible resolver estos problemas
si escuchamos a la razón, si escuchamos la clase de sabiduría que proviene de este tipo de mapas,
si escuchamos a personas como Snow y Whitehead
si escuchamos a los vecinos que entienden
lo que está en juego en este tipo de situaciones.
Y lo que finalmente sucedió es que permitió que la idea
de una sociedad urbana a gran escala fuera posible y sostenible.
Cuando las personas veían al 10 porciento de sus vecinos muriendo
en el transcurso de siete días,
todos estaban de acuerdo en que esto no podía seguir así,
que la gente no había sido destinada a vivir en ciudades de 2.5 millones de habitantes.
Pero debido a lo que Snow hizo y por este mapa,
es por lo que toda esta serie de reformas,
que se dieron a partir de este mapa,
que ahora damos por sentada la existencia de ciudades de 10 millones de habitantes.
Ciudades como esta son ahora cosas sustentables.
No nos preocupa que la ciudad de Nueva York vaya a colapsar
de la misma manera en la que, por ejemplo, le sucedió a Roma,
y reducirse al 10 porciento de su tamaño en 100 o 200 años.
Este es, en cierto sentido, el último legado de este mapa.
Es un mapa de muertes que terminó creando una nueva manera de vivir,
la vida que disfrutamos hoy día. ¡Muchas gracias!